ja vielen Dank für die Möglichkeiten
dazu sagen ich bin ja jemand der jeden
Tag mit Corona umgehen muss sowohl mit
Patienten die Corona haben als auch mit
Leuten die geimpft werden wollen
ich finde dieses Diskussion die wir im
Moment die ganze Zeit führen schwierig
weil wir eigentlich die medizinischen
Grundlagen verlassen haben jede
Medikamenten Zulassung hat in
Deutschland zu recht gutes Recht ja und
wir brauchen dafür auch Zeit und Daten
ja und deswegen war für mich so diese
Frage wann kriegen wir den Impfstoff
müssen wir jetzt haben und
was passiert dann wenn er da ist jetzt
ist er da jetzt ist er angepasst wir
haben genügend Impfstoff das sind ja
alles Änderungen die eingetreten sind
und wir haben jetzt eigentlich nur die
Aufgabe alle die die geimpft werden
wollen zu impfen und müssen uns nicht
eigentlich um die kümmern die vielleicht
20% oder so weiter die nicht geimpft
werden wollen und das ist ja ganz gutes
Recht dass sie selber zu entscheiden nur
ist es auch kein Recht durch eine
nichtimpfung andere Leute anzustecken ja
und das ist mein tägliches Praxisproblem
wir haben keine getrennten Räume wir
können keine infektierten Patienten
Trennen von anderen und wir haben frisch
operiert wir haben Tumorpatienten im
Wartezimmer und die erwarten meiner
Meinung nach zurecht dass wir dafür
sorgen dass kein akuter corona-fall in
der Praxis die anderen anstecken kann
fremdschutz oder also ich bin also wenn
man geimpft ist dann kann man doch
trotzdem also andere einstellen jeder
Impfung so aber immerhin ist es ja so
dass die geimpften selber schwere selten
schwere erkranken ja das ist der
einzelne Ausnahmefälle gibt
weiß ich nicht wenn er nicht krank wird
schon
die Frage ist doch ich muss doch nicht
sagen weil jemand mit Corona im Raum ist
mit der tumorpatient krank da muss ich
ja noch anstecken da gibt es nur Masken
zwischen da gibt es Abstandsregeln und
so weiter nur ich finde diese ganz
Diskussion dass wir mit Corona dauerhaft
umgehen müssen sollten wir einfach mal
zur Kenntnis nehmen und da sagen früher
war alles besser selbst die Zukunft das
ist nicht der Punkt wir müssen damit
lernen umzugehen und nicht sie haben
mich als corona-experten beschrieben ich
würde mich als jeden Tag neu lernen in
der bezeichnen weil es ist halt eine
neue Infektionskrankheit und wie wir
damit umgehen müssen auch wir lernen und
dass wir Impfstoff haben dass wir da
Möglichkeiten haben und vor allen Dingen
so schnell ist ja auch wieder Diskussion
waren wir nicht zu schnell nein wir
waren nicht zu schnell wir haben alle
Schritte gemacht nur mal schneller als
es bisher der Fall war deswegen ich
bleibe dabei dass man Diskussionen dann
führen sollte wenn man Daten hat über
die man reden kann und über die man sich
austauschen kann und nicht die Gerüchte
aufbringt und dann Zugang an die
Gerüchte könnten ja wahr sein wir
erzählen die schon mal daher stimmt's
noch
eine eine Frage zur Kommunikation hat
Herr Lauterbach nicht genau das getan er
hat gesagt die Impfung ist
nebenwirkungsfrei war sie da nicht er
hat gesagt die Impfung bietet
fremdschutz hat sie da nicht also nicht
genau das in der Kommunikation passiert
ich fand das gerade so angenehmer als
sie gesagt haben ich möchte gar nicht
als corona-experte bezeichnet werden ich
bin lernen darf wir müssen dazu lernen
aber genau das hat die Politik doch nie
vermittelt man hatte doch das Gefühl die
wissen alles oder nicht weiß ich nicht
ob er Lauterbach immer richtig zitiert
worden ist oder ob man nur das
ausgeschrieben hat was man dann genau
wissen wollte ich kenne Herr Lauterbach
von einigen Diskussionen im tsvg da war
er noch nicht Gesundheitsminister ich
weiß dass er eigentlich sehr fundiert
diskutieren kann wenn man ihn lässt und
wenn er nicht zum Beispiel in der Rolle
ist aber die ganze Diskussion zu führen
bevor sie von dir mit Fakten da ist auch
welchen Uni Shop lässt man wie zu was
muss da drin sein wie muss der aussehen
und so weiter
das hätte man im stillen Kämmerlein wir
haben eine Deko und ständige
Impfkommission die halt sagen kann wann
was wie zugelassen wird und die
stickomitglieder sind Ehrenamtler die
eigentlich aller nebenbei noch arbeiten
dass die der sich die heftigste Mühe
gegeben haben dass so schnell wie
möglich zu machen mit zweifel ich nicht
aber ich bin ja auch gewohnt damit
umzugehen alle anderen Impfungen sind
auch über die stego gelaufen die
Impfempfehlungen habe ich wir hören mal
einmal rein was Herr Lauterbach heute
gerade heute gesagt hat auch zum Thema
Impfen ist ja immer besser als über ihn
zu reden er sagt ja genug in der
Öffentlichkeit hören wir mal rein
es ist leider nicht so dass die Pandemie
vorbei ist sondern wir erleben derzeit
allenfalls eine Atempause wir sind auch
gewahrt dass wir damit rechnen müssen
dass andere Varianten uns in den
nächsten Monaten noch vor
Herausforderungen stellen werden wir
wissen derzeit noch nicht genau
beobachtende Studienlage aber sehr
präzise wie gut unsere vivalenten
Impfstoffe mit denen wir derzeit die
boosterimpfungen vornehmen wirken werden
das können wir noch nicht genau sagen
da habe ich mir die Frage ganz klar
gestellt erhöht das die Glaubwürdigkeit
daran sich impfen zu lassen wenn hier
hat er Lauterbacher eigentlich selbst
seine nicht Zweifel aber er hat ja
gesagt wir wissen es noch nicht so genau
wäre es dann nicht fast ehrlicher zu
sagen wir wissen auch noch nicht ob sie
wirken
nein wir haben ja gerade diese
Impfstoffe gefordert um uns an die
aktuellen Varianten anzupassen die er
wirklich vom Zusammenbau anders sind als
die bisherigen und dass die bisherigen
nicht so gut vorangehen egal jetzt in
welche Variante schützen wissen wir wir
haben danach gerufen und haben gesagt
wir brauchen ein angepassten Impfstoff
den haben wir jetzt und natürlich ist
bei jedem Impfstoff die Sache die gut er
schützt weiß man erst nachdem er geimpft
worden ist und nicht vorher und die
Daten brauchen wir halt durch die
geimpften aber wir gefährden sie ja
nicht wir haben eine Zulassungsverfahren
gemacht in jeglicher Form und wir
entgehen
gleich vom Stuhl ich muss da dringend
mal was zu sagen also es ist ja wirklich
es ist ja wirklich sie sind ja Herr Dr
Welling sie sind ja wirklich durch
verschiedene Bereiche gerannt ich will
das mal rückwärts wieder aufrollen also
die Zulassung gibt ja keinen Freibrief
dafür dass es nicht am Ende
Nebenwirkungen gibt also ich war jetzt
zum Beispiel im Bundesverwaltungsgericht
beim Prozess der Duldungspflicht der
Soldaten in Leipzig dabei da war Oberst
Arzt Prof dr Kehl der Berichterstatter
für des Bundesverteidigungsministerium
und er hat ganz klar gesagt ein Soldaten
haben wir verloren wegen der Impfung so
der ist durch die Impfung gestorben
Punkt das ist eine amtliche Information
die ist vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht
ausgesprochen der ist gestorben dann
haben wir mindestens 54 schwerst und
schwerwiegende Nebenwirkungen gehabt bei
den Soldaten bei den deutschen Soldaten
nachdem aber die Bundeswehr auf Ihre
Internetseite immer noch sagt vertragen
alle so wie sie das gesagt haben es ist
nicht so und die 54 schwerst und alle
Impfungen das Hervorbringen er hat nicht
gesagt wir haben schon über kovic gerade
gesprochen und dann haben Sie jetzt Wahl
angebracht
aber ich will trotzdem ich will das
trotzdem mal fortführen weil da sind so
viele Sachen die sie sagen die ich von
Ärzten höre die sich gar nicht mit den
Zahlen auseinandersetzen die behaupten
das einfach und ich glaube das hängt
auch an der 500 Millionen Euro Kampagne
von der Bundesregierung die tatsächlich
500 Millionen Euro in die sogenannte
aufklärungskamp hier gesteckt hat die
Frage steht jetzt wenn man aufklärt dann
gehört ja auch dazu über die Risiken
aufzuklären also bezeichne ich das als
Werbekampagne und so wird es auch
teilweise ja gesagt Impfkampagne wird ja
nicht gesagt Aufklärung Werbung ich muss
doch meine Leute auch darüber aufklären
dass das gewisse Risiken gibt und sie
tun ja gerade so als wäre das
nebenwirkungsfrei aber das ist es dir
führen jetzt so gerade keine
impfgespräche wir führen das weil sie
gesagt haben in der Klinik wäre ein
fremdschutz gegeben denn dann sind sie
davon abgerückt das hat er Lauterbach
auch gemacht ich bin nicht von der
Klinik ich habe noch nie haben gesagt
sie sind in der Klinik und da müssen sie
ja auch aufpassen dass die Leute sich
nicht anstecken und dafür müssen sie
geimpft sein ich bin in der Praxis in
der Praxis
in denen und da müssen die Leute geimpft
sein damit sie sozusagen nicht und dann
hat habe gesagt dass der Patienten die
da sitzen nicht angesteckt werden wollen
das habe ich gesagt aber die werden ja
durch die geimpften eingesteckt unter
anderem genau
Patienten es ist so es gibt ja zahlen
und wir sehen ja dass die es gibt ja
Gruppen die sind stark durchgeimpft das
sind ja gerade Klinik und
Krankenhauspersonal man hat ja von denen
verlangt dass sie sich impfen lassen und
man hat ja erhofft dass es dann und
dadurch zu wenige Ansteckung kommt wir
haben zum Beispiel das Uniklinik nicht
so gewesen nee das ist nicht so gewesen
ist sogar mehr Ansteckungen gemerkt
durch die Impfung ja okay es ist so dass
die Uniklinikum Eppendorf zum Beispiel
die haben auf Ihre Internetseite
wunderschönen Verlauf da können Sie
wunderbar sehen dass sie dort eine bei
einer Klinik mit 14.400 Beschäftigten
dass sie eine Inzidenz dort errechnen
können können sie sich teilweise bis zu
1.400 Beschäftigte gehabt die wegen
Corona ausgefallen sind und die Inzidenz
derer ist deutlich überhöht seit Ende
März 2022 gegenüber der Vergleichsgruppe
in Hamburg jetzt denkt man okay ist
vielleicht ein Klinikum ist vielleicht
stimmt irgendwas nicht und man kann es
vielleicht nicht vergleichen bei der
Bundeswehr ist das genauso bei der
Bundes haben wir 183.000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten und die sind ja durch die
Duldungspflicht auch verpflichtet
gewesen haben eine Impfquote von bis zu
97 Prozent und dort haben wir eine
Ansteckungsrate die liegt deutlich über
der Vergleichsgruppe der 15 bis
59-Jährige aber wir haben gegen den
altes Virus geimpft und wir haben
Momenten neue Erkrankungsfälle zumindest
seit diesem Jahr welche Zahlen nehmen
sie denn jetzt gerade
also Sie haben ja das Problem dass sie
immer mit Studien arbeiten und dass sie
immer sagen ich arbeite mit Patienten ja
gut aber sie haben nur wenige Patienten
sie haben vielleicht im Quartal 1000
Patienten oder so und das ist natürlich
stimmt so nicht ich habe bis zu drei im
Fallen betreut und habe 5000 Leute pro
Tag geimpft
alleine aber ist ja kein Beurteilung ist
krankheits-
okay